[Musique]
la composition intervient très très très
tôt quoi mais on s'inspire de
conseillère de ce qu'on a en nous et de
ce qui ne sort pas généralement on
exacerbe une une chose qui est en
général la tente
la colère le les grandes les grandes
émotions
il n'y a pas de nouvelle génération il
ya des acteurs et il ya surtout il ya un
goût du public qui change quoi c'est
surtout ça c'est que le public devient
enfin et quant aux brillants à souhait
est que et qu'il aie qui a les spasmes
de temps en temps et que les picards et
puis kalou tout le monde d'un coup il
découvre qu'il a envie de voir du une
certaine eu un certain état d'esprit
d'acteurs et puis voilà et puis il élit
alors sommes en ce moment on les lui
c'est un ou deux c'est à nous de de
passer le pack entre la mode et le
durable
ben oui non c'est là que l'acteur moi
j'ai pas que l'acteur est fragile enfin
en tout cas - ouais non en tout cas pour
ma part je suis pas je suis pas fou
furieux la fragilité des acteurs non
sincère je suis pas un jeu je vais pas
vous défendre ce à quoi agiter acteur ça
nous avons plutôt tendance à me gonfler
moi personnellement ça parce que je
trouve que effectivement mon choisy qu
est ce qu on fait comme dit françois
cluzet souvent c'est ça ou usine alors
il faut quand même être honnête c'est
mieux cuisine alors les acteurs fragile
qui se posent des problèmes qui
n'existent pas mise à part que c'est un
moyen nouveau de s'exhiber
ça m'intéresse pas outre mesure
tous les comédiens les artistes que l'on
voit s'engager pour l'état de causes
humanitaires charitables ou politique
j'en suis vous en êtes
certains disent les comédiens n'ont pas
affiché leur mais certains il est certes
un certain qu'on vous avez au courant de
ça vous savez moi je moi moi je dis que
si ça aide
je joue le jeu volontiers très
volontiers parce que ça c'est une forme
de putasserie qui me plaît bien
moi je veux bien faire la [ __ ] pour la
pour humanitairement je viens faire la
[ __ ]
ça ne dérange pas du tout on peut me
demander tout ce qu'on veut en tant
qu'acteur mais mais tout le reste quand
ces photos interviews il faut il faut
plus horrifique
il faut plus rien me demander que moi
même comme ce que je sais pas faire
autre chose alors je vais pas un très
bon client pour certains pour certains
jours je suis pas très bon pied
[Musique]